poi mi ero piccola romano di quelle
bambine che saltavano sempre soggetti e
non dava quanti genitori di contorno
summer dando nel letto dei miei genitori
ho sentito mio padre che sta valutando
se mi amate mi voleva saltare sull'altro
megawatt delle botte mentre i dossier
mai saltare insomma sta voci concorrere
con sbattuto contro il letto e la paura
non sono scaturiti dai ragazzi di tutto
il piede del letto
la città di pachino insomma o salato
animano la paura che anche persona
verginità titolo quattro anni quindi lei
caduta letto con il piede nella pagina
che si affacciano in via beata lei ha
sbattuto l'arcata nella vagina malata
[Risate]
auguri quanto riguarda cazzate tutti
una volta di libero.it la mia compagna
[Applauso]
cioè non si sta cercando di sentire la
tavola cambiano senza niente
io voglio sentire qualcosa
[Applauso]
smettila fino alla faccia della festa
per quanto riguarda io no mi spiace
mortificato noi andiamo avanti per
quanto riguarda
[Musica]
aspetti direbbe compagni deve prima e
seconda elementare
[Musica]
non sono un fan possono averci messo
sette ore per telethon c'era un continuo
e più questo costo di sora luigi scusato
neve ora che mi faceva troppo ridere a
mamma è stata una forte causa dei lavori
in casa 15 4 con i muratori che facevo
una qualunque durante l'ora di pranzo
gli amici andavamo praticamente a
recuperare i pranzi di questi poveri
quindi le rosette con la mortadella o
addirittura birra ragazzi tempo dieci
giorni epatite a un misero 25 anni
capito che si deve alla birra dei ha
fatto il sacco di cazzate quando ero
piccola mi perdevo mi nasconderò più
strana è che quando ero piccolo mi bevo
l'acqua che le vie qui ci sarebbe da
dire però sono allibito esatto anch'io
mi trovo un pochino in difficoltà cosa
facciamo una rosetta col prosciutto una
rosetta qualcuno bresaola invece per
l'euro è bello la7 con bus che genera da
parlare e poi siamo molto uniti
una volta andiamo in vacanza stavamo
cercando enrico da tutte le parti vinci
pensava che l'avessero peso trafficanti
di organi per ora questi tra mitiganti
alla fine è stato trovato sotto il
lavandino a dormire a dormire chi
volesse addormentato sul banner caprio
ma riusciva da casa ma io ce l'ho ma io
ce nostre cose lasciate finito in tutto
mi fai ricordo proprio che ho detto ma
io sono un po stanco ho visto stesso
bambino che era
intorno colpevoli tante ma bambino
quando c'avevo tipo cinque anni i miei
hanno comprato la nostra pelle
ma tutto questo rumore come prima
lattica neanche dopo sei ore che ce
l'avevamo dovevo andare lì con un sasso
e incidere in un cuore su cosa vi voglio
bene
le botte che ci ho preso le mazzate
sopra i denti e mi fai kabul a kimi
casco il primo dente perché anche preso
un sacco di botte che avevano sfondato
questo è brutta perché non è che lei
pensa te fanno sapere sempre una
violenza per un bambino ed una di fare
una cosa carina e poi come quando io
volevo portare la mia ragazza ve lo
ricordate a casa è pensato di fare una
cosa che vive parlo di veramente di
portare la mia ragazza a casa tutto
bello felice e voi avevate fatto un
collage di tutte foto tipo nude
trovassimo c profumi legare una
trascinante sul comodino sulla carne il
tuo comodino per farle credere agli
input quando non si trovavano oggetti in
casa io ero convinta di averle nell'anno
dunque questa cosa di lasciare i
commenti sta sfuggendo di mano quasi un
giorno farai un episodio di vita buttata
sulle figure tv parte due dato averla
già fatto né una super fantastica da
raccontare
noi siamo comunque consulenza nella
cupezza nasconde ma non lui
dovremo parlarne
quindi quando terrorizzando i bambini
facevano già parlato e non ha fatti
tanti
quella del buco della tasca già ci
faceva finta dove le mani impegnate
abbiamo fatto 90 c'è già stato pure
questo gabriele ci mette c'è stato il
genere della volta sì il bisogno
intervento lo stupido e la g ne sono
cammino però quello della sirena andava
descritto meglio cambia e che tu ti sei
cuscito la coda che poi l'ha fatta pure
discretamente che per la destra
provicina di pilota che esposte tutte le
voci da di ceci e lenticchie come parte
di corrado musical tipo di beni la tua
zuppa grazie torna mangiato mi sono
mangiato da solo degli operai si
vergognava abbiamo detto che rivela come
fiamo perché si vergogna ma voglio
sentire come commercio
[Musica]
ma da chi dice di no tesoro viola
scioccata e mangiati camuffata che cos è
uscito se non ne ha bayern anni cani si
arriverà gli ultrà sua volta che ragazza
era fatta
lo so io voglio metterla solamente
perché un album e della mente diamole
musicali e siamo arrivati alla fine di
questa puntata ma il vico il giorno in
cui ho fatto venire queste persone
all'interno di questa rubrica che
vogliamo bene anche noi da casa per
finirlo e ricordate sempre cosa di
ricordare e ricordate sempre di
ricordare io vi ringrazio per averci
seguito ma soprattutto vi chiedo uno di
farvi sapere quali sono stati pagati
delle cazzate che avete fatto da bambini
e che non avete avuto il modo di dirmi o
che magari mi avete detto e non avete
visto all'interno del video non c'è fine
bootcamp chiedo anche quello che fossero
venute delle idee per eventuali temi di
farmi sapere qua sotto che sempre un
piacere farci venire delle idee rubando
le vostre idee
ringrazio i miei fratelli per essersi
presentati la presa alta che mi inviterò
mi raccomando fate in modo di non
esserci trovate le scuse che altro dire
ragazzi no per lo sguardo verso sud
io l'ho fatto io ho fatto capire se il
primo sguardo commosso tutto il nostro
mostruoso
vabbè aspetta quindi
ma non è vero